the movie The Matrix everyone thinks
science fiction I go no no that's a
documentary everybody got programmed
that's a fact that's a biological
reality but what was interesting they
always said well there's a red pill and
you could take the red pill you get out
of the program and I go guess what
almost everybody in our audience is
taking that red pill at one time changed
their life it turns out science has
recognized that when you fall in love
you stop playing the programs and you
start creating from your conscious mind
wishes and desires are conscious mind
and so once you let go of the program
and you start creating wishes and
desires it's called the honeymoon
created this heaven on Earth experience
and I go you could have that every day
for every day of your whole life yes we
created that and if you understand you
created then you can say well why didn't
I create it tomorrow and I go you can
create it every day that's the beautiful
part hey seven Carmichael and I make
these videos because running the
business is hard and waking up every day
and getting to work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
how to get what you think about enjoy
rule number two is attract positivity
with Gabby Bernstein we're always
able to lean into two different energies
which is a topic we've spoken about
often here on the show
but when people say oh I want to get
myself into a attracting power I want to
manifest more into my life they often
think that it's something that they need
to do like I need to
make a vision board or I need to talk
about it a lot or I need to affirm how I
want to feel or I need to do do I need
to meditate more I need to read that
book when really the Simplicity is that
it's not so much about what we do but
it's about how we feel
when we feel good we attract more good
into our life that is a core through
line of this show dear Gabby it comes up
over and over and over again and this
card as it says when I'm connected to my
joyful presence I attract support from
the universe for me listen I try to find
even the most difficult circumstances as
an opportunity to lean into something
that's a better feeling vibration so
sometimes you may be thinking well how
could I lean into Joy when I'm dealing
with a diagnosis or when I have just
lost my job or when I am having
struggles in my marriage or whatever the
problem might be
this is when we really have to get to
work those moments when things are
difficult and there isn't joy in sight
that's when we have to do our best to
lean into the next best feeling
vibration rule number three is stay open
with Michael laysinger this whole thing
about abundance and attracting to
yourself what it is that you want and
how to use mantras and spirituality to
make sure you have what you want true
spirituality is about not wanting true
spirituality is about being filled with
joy from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want is there a law of
attraction people ask me is there a law
of attraction yes and you better be
scared of it because if it's true that
you attract what your mind is thinking
you better take a look at what your mind
is thinking it's not only when you're
sitting there trying to attract
something to yourself with affirmation
what about your mind all day when it's
complaining and it's yelling at people
and it doesn't like stuff but if you're
attracting that way so you eventually
catch on that it is not about getting
what you want
it is about learning to find out that
what you really want is to stay open and
not have conditions on that openness and
then it comes down to how do you do that
are people capable of doing that or is
that just reserve for you know some
special beings Buddha and Christ that
have walked the face of the Earth
everybody is capable of that how do I
know that
if I tell you to pick up five thousand
pounds you may not be able to do that in
fact you won't you won't be able to do
that so I've told you to do something
that you have never done and you're not
doing it so you may not be able to do it
but if you're actually already doing
something
you're already doing it and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it so inside you are the one who's
closing your heart you close it you are
the one who's closing your mind you do
that they're your thoughts it's your
feelings they're nobody else's so you
are in there doing these things so if I
tell you the way to stay open is to not
close I don't teach how to stay open
that's more like finding out how to get
what you want I'm interested in you
learning to not close but a difference
if I say to you I want you to open your
heart right now you wouldn't even know
how to start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only lasts a minute I'm
going to see a beautiful sunset you feel
like oh my God I looked in the face of
God then you go right back into your
mind with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want to teach the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching you how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is raise your
vibration with Bob Proctor when you talk
about money Bob uh you know I feel
aligned with that too the idea of
I I grew up in a mindset of where I
often thought that you know money was
the root of all evil or that money meant
someone had to do something negative to
get it or you always had just enough to
survive and I I find that we still see
that Paradigm existing in society but
see when you talk about money and even
when I learned with the monks where we
really understood the value of money you
see it as a as an energy source of
service you see it that's what it is
yeah exactly you see it as an energy
source of service of helping of giving
of providing tell us about that mental
shift that's made because I feel that
you're obviously a teacher in the Law of
Attraction and and you know popularized
and shared that concept how about when
what are some of the myths with the law
of attraction when it comes to money
because I find that there are a lot of
misuses or misapplications of the Law of
Attraction when it comes to money oh
listen and it comes law of attraction
it's almost synonymous with ignorance
hardly hardly anybody understands the
law of attraction
the um the secret of course
and you know
really blew up the law of attraction in
a big way caused a lot of people to
think about it but we didn't explain it
properly on that movie didn't get into
it in depth and most people don't know
how to get into it in depth attraction
um
is not a it's a secondary law it isn't a
primary law the primary law is a lot of
vibration and the law of vibration
decrees that everything moves nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion
circulation being one of the first laws
in the universe when stuff when
circulation stops death sets in
well
we operate on a frequency you do I do
and what we're really attempting to do
is raise the frequency that we're
operating on we want to operate on a
higher frequency all the time because
that's where
the real beauty of life is
well this thing we're living in is a
molecular structure in a very high speed
of vibration
and the brain is an electronic switching
station that alters the vibration we're
in
well we operate on a frequency and the
only thing we can attract to us is that
which is in resonance with us
so the reaction is actually attraction
is like Emerson said the law of cause
and effect was the law of laws action
reaction is the law of cause and effect
well our thoughts feelings and actions
we send off
into the universe it's a vibration
the universe sends it back it responds
in like manner well the response of the
universe is the attraction
you can only attract to you what
vibrates in harmony with you so if we
see things coming into our life that we
don't like let's understand what we
don't like is in harmony with something
inside
so we better try and understand what it
was or what it is and then get rid of it
attractions a secondary law
and we've got to understand it is
very real and you only attract to you
what you're in harmony with
when you want something that's on a
higher frequency you've got to operate
on that higher frequency because all the
thoughts and things that you require are
on that higher frequency
most people I say are living on an AM
frequency trying to listen to FM music
doesn't work how do you know what
vibrational frequency level you're
operating at uh because people often
judge their
people judge their performance by their
productivity by their efficiency we're
not trained as you said with your
Paradigm again going back to that we're
not trained to observe our frequency and
vibration and people are not sure so if
someone's listening and watching us
today how do they know what their
vibration or their frequency is how do
they diagnose that well I think the only
way to do it is by the results you're
getting
it'll tell you right makes sense see the
results do tell the truth they don't lie
Spirit manifests through its polar
opposite always we're Spiritual Beings
Spirit flows to and through us
and will do anything for us whatever we
ask it'll give us
and we're asking in thought
so what we want to do is take a look
what have I been thinking take a look at
your results you'll know what you're
thinking
that's how you can tell the frequency
you're on you want to start
frequencies vibration vibrations feeling
when you say I feel bad what you're
really saying is I'm not in a very good
vibration
you say I feel particularly good you're
saying I'm in a pretty good vibration
conscious awareness of vibration is
referred to as feeling
um
so I think the way to really understand
the frequency and the vibrations you're
operating on is by the results you're
getting
yeah if you're continually having
problems in all areas of your life
you're on the wrong you're in the wrong
vibration you know very low level of
vibration
and we can change it now I teach that in
the seminars I have ways of illustrating
and everything and it's important and as
people get into it
they really like it see I think when you
hear the truth you'll know it
and
I came across I don't know it came to me
I guess I was searching for a way how to
explain that
when you hear the truth you'll know it
well
there's music in this room right now
there's music in your room you may not
hear it but we know it's here
it's being broadcast it's in the room
and we don't hear it because our ears
are not operating on the frequency of
the music is being broadcast on
but if we turned on a radio the radio
picks up on that frequency speeds it up
to Zippo way up onto higher frequent and
we can hear it
well
it's the receiver on the radio that
picks it up
sends it up on a higher level where you
hear it
when you hear the truth the truth
resonates with the essence of Who You
Are
and when it resonates IT sets up that
vibration it comes out on the conscious
level as knowing you just know
you just know that's right yeah when you
hear the truth you'll know I know it
that's true
well that's true when you're reading
something when a person says something
to you
you didn't just I know that's not true
I know that is true it resonates with
the essence and we there is perfection
our spiritual DNA is perfect
and when we hear the truth it's like
that's the receiver
and it clicks in you know rule number
five is rewire your brain with Joe
dispenza most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work we literally have to
become someone else in other words
thoughts are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how you think and how you feel
creates a state of being so most people
have experiences in their life that
brand them emotionally they feel fear
they feel anger they feel bitterness
they feel frustration they feel
insecurity and those emotions then
become part of their identity
so once they think certain thoughts that
turn on certain circuits in their brain
that are equal to their insecurity and
then they feel insecure the moment they
feel insecure they think more insecure
thoughts which makes more chemicals for
them to feel insecure
and the repetition of that cycle over
time conditions the body to
subconsciously become the mind of
insecurity
so then the person says I am insecure
and whenever you say I am anything
you're commanding your mind and body
towards a destiny so then most people's
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness you're not waiting for
your new relationship to feel love
you're not waiting for the mystical
moment to feel off you're not waiting
for your success to feel empowered
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in other words the
materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur
we have to feel love for ourselves and
love for life in order for us to have
love in our life and so then to instruct
people how to teach their body
emotionally how that future could feel
like before it's made manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred so the
process of change
and the meditative model requires
unlearning and relearning requires
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self
what we say in Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections unfiring and unwiring and
re-firing and rewiring
unmemorizing emotions that are stored in
the body and then reconditioning the
body to a new mind into a new motion no
longer signaling the same genes in the
same way but signaling new genes in new
ways
beginning to pull your energy out of the
past and beginning to invest your energy
into the future item number six the last
time before some very special bonus
Clips is take control of your mind with
John Kehoe I like to dialogue with my
mind
now that sounds quite funny to say that
you have a dialogue and a conversation
with your mind
but anybody that does deep work with
their mind whether through meditation
whether through contemplation whether
through mind power
whether simply observing how your mind
works is that you find is that your mind
is talking to you all the time
it's telling you things it's commenting
things are too it's too cold today or uh
I'm not comfortable today or I don't
like the people that I'm with or uh I
don't like my job or my marriage isn't
working out well or I wish I had more
money or isn't this a delicious meal or
so your mind is constantly
commenting and has a narrative and is
thinking all the time
and it's very valuable to first of all
know that and observe it
because one of the very first teachings
that I give in the mind power training
in in right the very beginning of
lecture number one
is that you are not your mind
and to realize that you're not your mind
that your mind is a part of you
and a very important part of you a very
valuable part of you often a very
distracting part of you
but it's only a part of you
you are much Beyond
simply your mind
and your mind talks to you all the time
so you get to talk to your mind as well
sometimes at night and this is quite
often when I do it
um lying in bed and I'm thinking
thoughts and and I'll just stop
and I'll ask my mind I'll say
what do you want to think about right
now
and the mind is kind of goes oh it it
feels seen it feels noticed it it it it
it feels actually a little bit
vulnerable it's like what do you mean
what do I want to think about well what
what would you like to think about
and the mind might say
I want to think about how upset I am
about some and it name some person an
incident that happened maybe a few days
ago or a week ago I want to think about
how terrible this person is
and you go okay you have that option but
can I give another suggestion to you
why don't you have compassion for this
person
why don't we
you and your mind why don't we have
compassion would you be willing to have
compassion for this person the mind says
no I don't want to have compassion and I
want to feel really angry
and you can say to the mind okay then
um you can be angry and and but you know
what how's that going to make us feel
why don't you be angry for let's be
angry for a couple minutes
and your mind gets really angry for a
couple minutes and then you go now how
does that make us feel
the mind says I I I'm angry I'm upset
well do we like this feeling no we don't
like this feeling
let's try compassion for this person
let's realize that maybe this person is
wounded internally maybe they're going
through a lot of problems and
difficulties and let's try compassion
let's do that for the next two minutes
and the mind says okay let's have
compassion for that person
and you have compassion for that person
for two minutes
and then you say to the mind how does
that feel
and the mind goes that feels much better
all right
then here's what we're going to do is I
will let you think what you want to
think sometimes
and you let me
think what we want to think
and I have different things for example
um it's been a long day today I think
that I would like to feel gratitude
right now
can we feel gratitude together do we
have anything to be thankful for in our
life the mind will say well let me think
and it will come up for reasons on why
to be thankful and you move into
gratitude
and so that's exactly
how you work with the mind at different
times when it could be maybe maybe you
know when you're when you're doing your
meditation or or throughout the day to
take out
I mean we take coffee breaks why not
take a mind break
why not take a break through your day
several times through your day
where the mind will think what you
wanted to think and you can work with
love
you can work with inner peace you can
work with gratitude you can work with
success you can work with faith I mean
there's so many ways that you can work
with the mind and get it to meditate and
contemplate or you can work with worry
you can work with fear you can work with
anger you can work with resentment
all these are possibilities
and the mind has a whole range of things
that it can think about
so the first thing is to be aware
that your mind is thinking all the time
and secondly
your mind is not you
you're separate from your mind your mind
is only a part of you you have the
ability and actually the responsibility
to dialogue with the mind
and to guide the mind and to train the
mind and instruct the mind and what I
found with the mind is the Mind loves to
be trained
the mind doesn't like to be out of
control the mind doesn't like to be fear
and worry it just it falls into that
trap
and it falls into that trap because it
doesn't have you guiding it
but when you can enter into dialogue and
guide your mind your mind will become
your best friend your absolute best
friend your biggest supporter
and you'll be quite a team together
your personality literally ad is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in the mood why are
you in a mood well this thing happened
to me five days ago and I'm having one
long emotional reaction so then what you
do is you keep telling the story about
it keep firing and wiring the same
circuits and you keep conditioning the
body into the past so then you wake up
in the morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away wow to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though
it's been addicted to that emotion
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened or it's happening
to you so the moment you open your heart
and you feel gratitude well that emotion
then is telling the body that the
experience has already occurred and the
thought then can make it into the body
because it's consistent with the thought
so now you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email then I would say oh my God
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life
unless of the victim of your life how do
we reshape our self-image to serve us as
opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting molts
Maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon and he found
if he operated on a person maybe they
had a distasteful scar in their face
and he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
yeah but he said other times they'd
remove the scar who was very successful
no change in their personality
that led him to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror we have an
inner image of ourselves
it's how we see ourselves right now that
inner image is an idea
and that idea is generally
planted in our little life when we're
infants
and it's planted by virtue of the the
environment that we're surrounded by
how we're raised if a child's raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us
that image was planted by people it
didn't know what the hell was going on
they didn't know the war was over and
they were planting they were developing
a little mind it was a mind they were
shaping it like fresh clay they didn't
understand that it was a kid they're
looking after him we feed him we keep
him warm up to hell you know that's our
responsibility no it was a mind and they
were developing that mind and if they
didn't understand what were they going
to put in well all they could give to
the child is the insecurities that they
had themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of themself now I grew up very
insecure I was born during the
Depression when I first went to school
the second world war had just broken out
so everybody's rationed for everything
it was hard times all the men were away
fighting in Europe or South Pacific
there was no men doing nothing the women
that were there were driving the trucks
there were cops they did everything so
there wasn't a whole lot of time used
for developing a little mind
so I just grew up and picked up what I
could and I grew up very insecure it
wasn't until I met a man that gave me
this book and gave me some damn good
instruction and I started to pay
attention to who I was
and I have never stopped being
fascinated with studying me yeah I I am
the most fascinating subject that I've
ever come across
and I have found out that you and I are
exactly the same we only appear to be
different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
but our potentials exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties we're both Spiritual Beings we
both drawn an infinite source of supply
we're the same
so the trick I think for the person that
has insecurities that hasn't got the
strongest image they want they should
find a damn good Mentor
that's what changed my life first of all
the cause of fear is ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorant starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
that's on a conscious level we're
doubting or we're worrying then we take
whatever image comes into our
consciousness of the doubt and the worry
and we turn it over to our emotional
mind that's what causes the fear
well that fear then has to be expressed
through the body you're the only
instrument it can be expressed through
our physical body it sets up a vibration
known as anxiety
mm-hmm
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
Decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
um
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
um
now unfortunately
uh School
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us school should teach
us to love to study
not a dread studying and homework and
tests
love it
free which is understanding
see a study that leads to understanding
we understand how to handle the fear
it's understanding that enables us to
cause us to understand where the fear
starts the understanding then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the lies is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to Faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being
an expression
it's not depression it's not suppression
it's not anxiety the faith leads to
well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're athies we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with Polar Opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
it's by understanding not that we learn
how to deal with these pandemics when
they hit and they will head there will
be others
there always has been all down through
history if you look back there's been
things like this happen in the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it could you speak about
the neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no and the more we
remember the event the more we produce
the emotions that are associated with it
and we're conditioning the brain and
body further into the past yes or no and
it you keep doing it enough times it's
no longer conscious that you're holding
a grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer everybody can't
be trusted everybody is that same person
you're you're overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person that's the lens
that we're perceiving reality are you
with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this we
all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere and no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy is
going to move it's got to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion when you feel true true
kindness and care it's hard to hold the
grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a Quantum perspective you
are actually as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage because of that
person
and you were holding them hostage
because of that experience and you have
an energetic Bond that's connecting you
to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and I let them
go
so then forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the body
start getting a lift of energy once it
makes its here now you're going to see
that track sending in energy to the
brain the heart acts as an amplifier to
boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like I don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgive them
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
and when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event in
in
Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same way
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting I've never had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the restaurant
was quiet and then
I leaned back I'm suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zygon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh
I always thought about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to Lost like
you're out collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're going to go up to Vermont to
see the leaves and immediately I'm like
we got to go to Simon Pierce I gotta
show you the painting so we pull up to
the mill and we walk in and right in
front there is Boom a painting by the
same artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh
my God it's here and we race all around
the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was I literally
turned to him and said it's okay dude
like it'd be weird if we're still here
after 10 years I'm gonna track this
thing down I actually said to him you
know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell him the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris was like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountain
Escape behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying in
formation overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing and he kind of leans over and goes
hey Gail how much for the big one and
she said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want what is fear is fear
something that you should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe your low on tire air
pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism okay
develop and how does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential
Threat predator or threat at the door it
lights up the fear signals since
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the Predator will go
away so when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what's what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then knowledge then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what if succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great can you take
a picture of me with it so I put on
social media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same steak stain stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to
Skyrocket your wealth with this mindset
shift check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we have a
relationship with everything known in
our environment you have a relationship
a neurological Network in your brain to
for your parents for your cell phone for
your computer for the most part the
brain is a reflection of everything that
we know